hello
everybody and welcome to the
last session of the day where
i am going to talk about migrating your
web apps to
asp.net core one page at a time
and this technique works for
any kind of web app you can do it with
asp.net web forms asp.net mvc
theoretically classic asp
if you have a classic asp application
what else rails django pretty much
anything
but mainly web forms because
reasons um i'm mark rendell and
uh i have been working with net since
the first.net actually since the
first.net beta i downloaded the first
ever beta
of dot net 1.0 and then wrote a c sharp
program to run reflection over the
entire
base class library and give me all the
classes and methods and everything
and i've been really excited about all
the new.net stuff
um i was there with uh when it was
called project
k um and i actually put something into
production with project k
way back in the day in a docker
container um
and it was a micro micro service
that generated a guide you hit an end
point and it generated to give it
and it gave it back to you and the only
reason it existed was because
uh almost everything was written in node
and node is terribly slow at generating
goods
and it locks while it's doing it uh
mick mate could you mute yourself please
can i mute you there we go thanks very
much um
unless you were kind of going node is
very fast at generating viewings in
which case no it isn't
wrong um but yes so i
pulled gui generation out into a
microservice so that load didn't have to
work so hard and could keep
tracking people's movements over some
web pages um
but yes and now we're onto net 5.0
and now microsoft have essentially gone
all in
and said we are this is now.net the
old.net is the old.net and this is
new.net going forwards and everything
else and so
they haven't brought over various things
and one of the things they haven't
brought over is web forms and
a bunch of people are obviously quite
upset about this people have got
big complicated applications written
in asp.net web forms and we're talking
like hundreds of thousands or
millions of lines of code around the
world
there are probably billions of lines of
code
all wrapped up in asp.net web forms and
microsoft is not bringing it over and i
think that's a good thing
and the reason i think that is a good
thing
is because i have worked with a lot of
asp.net web forms
applications over the years and
after 20 years when you've got an
application that's started in
net 1.0 or net 2.0 and has been
maintained for the past
20 years by a succession of different
people
trying to maintain an asp.net web forms
application in 2021
is a dumpster fire yes it is you might
be saying
not all web forms applications you can
write clean web forms code and you can
use proper programming practices and
dependency injection and all this sort
of stuff not all web forms applications
are bad
to which i reply i have seen things you
people
wouldn't believe
i firmly believe that in this day and
age
the worst c-sharp code still in
production
exists entirely inside web forms
applications
i am not going to
show any examples because they all come
from real places
but recently i found
a method in an asp.net web forms
application
where they wanted they were trying to
correct common
spelling mistakes um if you spelled
document
wrong they would try and correct it and
so they had
a huge if statement that contained all
the possible
um misspellings of the word document
and i mean there were like 300 and
something
or pipes in this
if statement and
um and on every single one of those all
statements
they called dot trim on the variable
that contained the document name
so they created 300 strings in the
process of running this if statement
and that's just just one example you
know it's it's like
it's like a whole daily wtf and it's all
inside web forms code so
why would you want to move i mean let's
let's assume that you are one of the
people who
are not all web forms and actually yes
you've got a really really nice web
forms application and it's a joy to
maintain
and and you absolutely love it and you
wouldn't trade it for anything
at all why would you want to move to
asp.net core
well a variety of reasons first it runs
on linux
now that might not sound like a
particular
um reason to switch over but consider
that the hosting costs for linux
tend to be less than the hosting costs
for windows servers
especially in a cloud environment also
the fact that it runs on linux
means that it runs in containers which
means you can use
docker and kubernetes or azure container
services
or the digital ocean
droplets where you just go here's my
image run me that as a docker container
and all that good stuff and then you can
also get into service meshes and
all kinds of bunkers things that make
kubernetes so much fun
also asp.net core is stupid far and i
mean it is really
stupid fast um there's a great
little anecdote from waybacker
at ndc i think ndc oslo a few years ago
um where uh damien edwards and david
fowler
did a talk um on asp.net core
and how they were working on making the
performance better and it was a deep
dive into some of the things like did
you know for example
that when asp.net call checks the
http verb get put post delete that sort
of thing
it actually converts the utf-8 bytes
into a 64-bit integer and then just maps
against those
um to do a really quick look up of what
verb it is
which is much better than what node used
to do when it wanted to check where it
just
checked the first letter of the
method instead and so patch put and post
were all treated as the same thing
brilliant um but yes anyway they were
trying to make it fast and
when they first came out with the
kestrel http server
um kelly uh kelabite kelly summers i
think her name is
on linux was building her own http
server in c
and she benchmarked it and she
benchmarked kestrel and her server could
do like a million requests a second
and kestrel on the same hardware could
do 70 000 requests a second
and so she was come making fun of
of kestrel and apparently damian went
into the
the room where the developers on kestrel
were working and went
why why do we only do 70 000 requests a
second this is this is ridiculous
and they said you didn't say you wanted
it to be fast
and so he went yes make it fast please
that would be really good and so they
went off and they did and now it's
basically it's up near the top
of the benchmarks on the tech and power
benchmarks for the
plain text so the kestrel server itself
is fast
and there's a huge amount of effort
still going into things like making
database access fast and making json
serialization fast
so that it can climb further up the
benchmarks
on things like fortunes and database
updates and so forth
but the number one reason why you want
to move to asp.net core from asp.net
is that asp.net core is being actively
developed
people are working on it it is having
features added it is
supported by microsoft it's also open
source
so if you run into a problem and you
know how to fix it you can fix it and
send them a pull request
and you know so that's good too but the
fact is that asp.net core
is getting all the attention and love on
asp.net web forms
is getting none and
this is a problem because web forms is
not supported in dotnet or 5.0
because it would be really really really
difficult
to migrate all of web forms across quite
a lot of what happens inside web forms
is actually windows components
and so making it cross-platform they'd
have to rewrite a bunch of stuff
as dot-net components and they don't
want to do that
so you can't just bring your web forms
over to net core and then start
migrating it to mvc or whatever you want
to do
but also asp.net core doesn't run
on net4 it used to um the first version
of asp net core
did run on.net 4.6
and higher i believe but as they started
adding more things for performance and
everything else to.net core
um like span and memory and buffers and
all sorts of things where they were
actually changing the runtime
to make these things work um and they
were using these features a lot of these
features were driven by asp.net core
and so they had to make the decision say
asp.net core is going to only run
on.net core and now.net five
and so there's no sort of a bit at a
time
path really to go from asp.net web forms
or asp.net
mvc to asp.net core
and when you've got a million lines of
code
in an application that's a big problem
because
you can't just go we're not adding any
new features and we're not doing any
support and we're not making any changes
to this existing application
until we have rewritten the whole thing
in asp.net core
we don't know asp net core we've never
used razer we don't know mvc we don't
understand the pattern
we're going to have to stop we're going
to have to learn that and then we're
going to have to migrate a million lines
of code
so come back in three years and we'll
add your feature then
not an option what you want is a way to
do it a page at a time
a little bit at a time now
i know of one solution to this and that
is a framework that is quite a lot like
web forms it looks a lot like web forms
it's syntax it's aspx style pages
are a lot like web forms but it's not
web forms it's a new open source
framework that is completely different
and this one does run on both net four
and dot net call 3.1 and net five
and so you can add this into your
visual studio there's a visual studio
extension
and then you open your web forms project
and you add
vvm to it and then you just start
migrating pages
and you can do quite a lot of copying
and pasting um
into the new thing and so that that
actually works
um apparently i don't really
know uh exactly how it works i don't
know what the support
situation is and you're kind of
signing up for this new um
framework to build your web application
on and it's not from microsoft
and so you don't know whether it's going
to be supported and i don't know if they
charge for it and all this sort of stuff
so
you know it's a possibility but it's not
a particularly
um it's not
the obvious solution it's not a kind of
yeah let's do that
what could possibly go wrong and then i
was just reading through my daily dose
of
um of
rss feed newsletter things and i saw a
blog post from somebody who's working on
something
and i happen to be working on a web
forms application at the moment
and not enjoying it and those two things
came together in my head and i went hang
on a minute
i've got a great idea
um i didn't go hang on a minute lads
because of the code of conduct i went
hang on a minute
i've got a great idea and if you haven't
seen the italian job
you don't know what i'm talking about
and you should watch the italian job
like
just stop watching me and go and watch
the italian job now trust me
um it's much better than listening to me
waffle on
i promise you okay um
a few people at home there i've got a
whole sort of screen here dedicated to
showing people who are in the room at
the moment
um and if you can turn on your webcam
um it would be really appreciated it's
really nice to be able to see people's
faces
and little lego engineers that they've
got in front of the webcam
and stuff like that hey tom it's also
really weird being able to see
everybody's name
when you're doing a talk at ndc you've
just got an audience you see your faces
and yet you might know sort of people
and go hey
um but yeah when you can actually see
people's names
and you sort of go oh i used to work
with you at um
morgan stanley um i i didn't know you
were here that's awesome
so yes um you know who you are
uh so yeah i had a great idea i thought
what about if because the thing that i
found
in my rss feeds was about something
called yap
and yarp stands for yet another reverse
proxy
and it's a microsoft project to build
a reverse proxy using
um
kestrel so you have a customizable
codable reverse proxy using kestrel
and so i thought and it just sits in
basically an asp.net core application
and so i thought well what if i made an
asp.net core application
that had mvc or razer pages or blazer or
whatever in it
and it also had this reverse proxy in
there
and so if it got asked for a page it
didn't know about
it would just proxy it on and then if i
point the proxy
at the web forms application
then it will just serve the web forms
application completely normally
but if um i then
in add a page to the mvc application
which matches the path that's being
looked for then it'll serve it from
asp.net core and then i could just i
could literally replace one page at a
time
so the thing that i was thinking of
using
yap yet another reverse proxy supports
dotnet core
3.1 and net 5.0 and it's currently
in preview um it's open source it's on
github microsoft slash reverse proxy
it's on nougat and we're on preview
versions of it at the moment but
i'm expecting it to be sort of stable
and
it certainly seems to work okay and so
this is a great idea i've had a
fantastic idea i have invented this
um i am a genius
and then i found out that this is
actually an established pattern
for doing this sort of thing um coined
by martin fowler in 2004 it's called the
strangler fig
pattern
it was originally called the strangler
has the same sort of origin and then
people pointed out that's a really nasty
word why would you call something that
please change it and so he changed it to
strangler fig
and it comes from the a whole
breed of plants called um strangler figs
or banyan trees and these things
actually germinate they germinate in
other trees
and then they grow and they roots and
they go down and down until they take
root and then they basically kill the
tree
that they have um that they've grown on
and
and taken the nutrients from and all
this sort of stuff and so you end up
with this
new tree that's bigger than the old tree
and fresher and all this sort of stuff
and
the old tree just dies and i thought
that's that's a really good
analogy for what i'm doing um
and so i started messing about with this
and i've just i also started streaming
and i thought this is a good opportunity
i'm going to go on twitch and people can
just watch me and and
laugh at me as i try and build this
thing and so
and i'm still doing it and i'm still
building it on twitch and so you can go
there and
watch me tuesdays and thursdays 7 pm uk
time
yes that was a massive plug no i don't
care shut up
um so let's do a quick demo
um i went onto twitter and i said what's
uh what the
sample applications for um
asp.net web forms and somebody pointed
me at
this the wingtip toys application
um this is
wing tip toys
you can tell it's web forms there you go
so yeah
and we've got cars and planes and trucks
and boats and rockets and all this sort
of stuff
and i thought okay i'm going to try and
stick an asp.net
mvc application in front of that and so
i'm going to show you roughly how this
went so i've got my solution here and i
mean dotnet 5.0
dot new mvc minus so src
backslash demo
dotnet sln add
src backslash demo and then we can
ryder and open this up in here
so here is my completely empty
boilerplate
asp.net mvc application which has got
all this stuff in it
okay so to this i am going to
add a new get package and i'm going to
have pre-release turned on and search
for microsoft
dot reverse proxy
and there it is a 1.0 preview eight
two one six 82106.5.1 let's add that in
here
and then you need to add
some configuration
to this i'm just going to open this one
up
which is my sort of crib sheet
so we go into
appsettings.development.json
and we're going to add in
this configuration here
so this basically says uh creator root
route 1 cluster 1
catch all define a cluster and we're
going to get this to point
at localhost 2401.9
which is our backend application
and then in startup i'm just going to
say
endpoints dot
map reverse proxy i'm going to leave
that
like that
and i think that is basically all of it
um oh no we need
services so we do services dot
add reverse proxy
dot load from config configuration dot
get section
reverse proxy like so
so now i've got my wingtip toys
application running now i'm going to run
my asp.net core application
and it's going to boot up like this
i'm going to go to here i'm going to go
to https localhost 5001.
and there you go that is my asp.net core
application
um which is pretending to be my wingtip
toys application
except it's a little bit weird because i
would expect this
to have caught the index page because i
know my
asp.net core application has an index
page so why isn't it
able to see it so a little bit of
experimentation with this
and it turned out that to get it to work
properly
you have to put explicit roots
on every single endpoint in your asp.net
core application
so if i now do this
and go back to here and do refresh you
see i get my
default page from my asp.net core
application
so that's that's what we wanted there
so now i need to figure out how to make
my asp.net core application
look like my um so i need this
sort of bootstrap bar up at the top here
now
if i were doing this properly if i were
doing this
um in a real situation
i would probably go to the trouble of
trying to create
a new bootstrap theme using bootstrap 5
that matched the old bootstrap theme
but this is quick and dirty so i'm not
going to do that
so i'm going to go into wingtip toys
and i'm going to actually you know what
this is going to take too long
i'm going to stop trying to write this
on the fly
and i am instead terminate that process
and i'm just going to jump into my
project that i'm using for testing my
thing at the moment
and i'm going to run this
and this is now going to show up in here
so in the immortal words of blue peter
presenters
here's one i prepared earlier
um something went running at me
so yes this is an
actual asp.net core application this is
coming
from the front end
the proxy application and you can tell
because if i go to about
you can see it says wingtip toys and
down here it says
so this is the old thing which has
wingtip toys
in the title bar and this is the new
thing which has wingtip toys too
and also has this admin link here and
all i basically did for this
was i copied um the
stuff out of the site master
on the old website and you can actually
see where i did it here
i've brought some old asp things across
and i turned it into a new um
mvc sort of turned it and put it into
the layout page and copied this
the bootstrap files across and all this
sort of stuff
and it essentially it worked except
with a couple of
downsides which is what i want to talk
about
for the rest of this talk because
um
what's going on in an application is not
just
with um tracy island i know
i i the thing is i was too old for tracy
island
um somebody asked about tracy island in
the chat and
uh if you are um a millennial or a
zoomer
you will not know what we're talking
about but um blue peter which was a
children's program
back in the day um there was a toy
released for christmas
uh tracy island from the thunderbirds
show and
everybody wanted the toy and it sold out
everywhere and people were
like completely cut up about it and blue
peter which showed you how to make
things
showed you over the course of about a
month how to make your own tracy island
and it was
epic it was huge and so everybody of my
generation still remembers
blue peter and tracy island
nice thing about doing conferences at
home is you can drink tea
which you've made yourself
so yes integration there are things that
are going on
on the server side that you need to be
able to communicate
between these two services and the first
one of these
is session so web forms applications
um certainly most of the ones i work on
make an awful lot of use of session um
and you know i see web forms
applications where they don't know about
query parameters
and so the way that they pass query
parameters from one page to another
is that they put them into session and
then they redirect
to the other page and then they pull
them out of session
again and
quite a lot of web forms applications
actually
use in process session because they just
they want to stick
objects in there they've got lovely
objects which they've defined which are
millions of miles deep and probably
multiple megabytes on the heap
and have self references circling all
over the place that you just have
no hope of serializing which means you
can't use out of process
session because there's no way of
getting the object from there to there
so they use in process session
and they use sticky load balancing to
make sure that people always get
directed
to the same server or
in some cases they just run one server
yes they really do
and so we need a way for the
asp.net core app to be able to go to the
web forms app and say hey i need
a value that you keep in session or
you know that value you keep in session
you need to change it
and so we need an api that goes
from the asp.net core app to the web
forms app
and so the first thing i did in my sort
of
adventures in coding that i was doing on
twitch
was i wrote a session
sharer and it eventually made its way
into a
library which i will tell you more about
later on
but in this application here
actually let's go to wingtip toys first
of all so
in this application here we are using
this package and we have a session api
handler
so the easiest way to put
end points into a web forms application
if you are just really set against using
web forms or creating asmx
pages or whatever however people used to
do
services in web forms you just create an
http handler and plug it into the
pipeline
and then you can distribute that in a
nuget package which is really nice
and so we create this api handler
that gets the http context in and it
just goes
do i have this value in session and if i
don't
um then or if you haven't specified a
key then we'll just return 400
and if i can't find it in session then
i'm just going to return 404
otherwise we'll serialize it to bytes
and we'll pass it back across the line
i remember what i said before about um
objects that you can't serialize
people are going to have to fix that
there's not a lot i can do
about it but for the most part we sort
of go if it's a string then just doing
coding dot get bytes so
if it's one of these things we can use
bitconverter.getbytes
um decimals and
dates and times are a bit more
complicated
but for those objects that people are
just going i just want to stick this in
session and have it there um
i thought about using binary converter
and
then i looked and microsoft have
binary converter exists in net
core i think they put it in in.net call
2.0 or 2.1
and there was much rejoicing because
people wanted to use it
but now they're kind of backing away
from it and going we really
really hate binary converter there are
all sorts of security issues with it
barry dorens gets very very upset
um and so we're kind of deprecating it
we're
basically we're not promising to support
it for any length of time
and so ah and then uh
what i actually use when i want to
serialize things to bytes
and pass them across things very quickly
is message back message pack is a
lovely binary serialization format
it's a bit like protobuf but it's much
easier to
integrate to a net application because
there's a brilliant message back library
that does it for you
and it will serialize objects
that it doesn't recognize it doesn't you
don't have to have a decorated object
and so i've just gone hey let's just use
message back so anything that we don't
know how to deal with we'll just use
message pack and serialize that
back across the wire and then on the
facade side
we just have a cocoon session
and this we register with
dependency injection not in here though
um and then in here we can just
say hey um
we've got a cache we'll keep a local
cache of the
session um so we only have to get each
value once
um but we'll do this get async otherwise
we will talk to the
web app at the back end and we will go
and get
that session value out of there
um and so in this particular application
um i just go to here
and if i go to rocket so this page is
being served
from the web forms application and i do
add to cart
and that takes me to the cart page here
and now
the cart is actually in the in a sql
database that's being used by the
backend application
but when i go to my home page here
the key for that cart is stored in
session
and so just to make this cart
brackets one thing work in my asp.net
core mvc application
it had to talk to the backend
application and say what's the cart id
for the current session get that back
and then
i've just created a link to the database
and i am recreating what was entity
framework
in the web forms application
and i'm basically just copying the
entity classes across so i've got cart
item and category
and product but i've created a
standard entity framework core 5.0
context just created these
db sets for those classes and it just
worked
i didn't have to do anything i didn't
have to change anything
on the
classes here i just left everything as
it was i could even link to those
classes
um rather than import them in but i
thought no i don't want to do that
so yes and then i created a tag helper
so um in wingtip toys
in sight.master that cart link
is done we've got this cart count here
i have no idea where that gets set from
but let's do a ctrl shift f
there we go we've got a pre-render
and that creates a new shopping cart
actions and gets the cart count
and then renders that in there so of
course it does because this is
asp.net web forms um
so yes that's how that does that whereas
i have a cartlink tag helper
that basically says uh
in my layout code here
i can just have a cart link see
razer asp.net call razer mvc tag helpers
are
epic so this cart link is a tag helper
that gets
turned into an ae href equals
and has the date the amount of
things you've got in your cart added to
it and all this is done
um so we have the shopping cart there
and the shopping cart is another thing
that gets pulled in and you can see
we've got cocoon session gets pulled in
here and db context gets pulled in here
and that drags that across and then
returns the count
back out considering it's having to do
all that
it actually loads really quickly i'm
quite impressed
so that was authentication
that was um session rather so the next
thing
is authentication because
um
logging in to the site at the back
um you want that person to be logged in
with the same identifier on the site on
the front
and so that was uh challenging
and so for that i had to write uh
another section to this
set of libraries and we have an
auth api handler um and
this one just it gets the hcp context
and says
if it's a claims principle then if it's
not authenticated we'll just return 401
to say it's not authenticated otherwise
we're going to serialize a claims
principle
has anyone ever tried serializing a
claims principle
in.net for shout out in the in the chat
and tell people
why it doesn't work um circular
references
fundamentally there are many many
circular references
in a claims principle but i was not
deterred
i will not be stopped from doing
crazy things just because dotnet doesn't
want to play with me
so turning back to message pack again
and this time i have control i know what
the object i want to serialize is
i know it won't serialize so i can
actually create proper message pack
objects
um with a list of identities and i can
convert between a claims principle
and a message pack version of claims
principle
and i can serialize that back across as
well
and i can also i can remember to call
context.response.flushandcontext.response.end
every single time otherwise i lose two
hours just going around in circles
trying to find out why things aren't
working
and then on the facade side this is
different from session this is
um not just i need a value from the back
end
this is actually a key part of the whole
web application
experience and so i need to get this
integrated properly
and so i had to create my own
authentication handler
for asp.net core
and so we have a cocoon authentication
handler here
which derives from authentication
handler
which is built into asp.net core so this
is
authentication handler is the same place
that cookie authentication handler
and basic authentication handler all of
those derive from this
so actually quite a lot of the work is
already done for you
and so we have um
a uh we have to override handle
authenticate async
and we have to override handle challenge
async
and this uses configuration to say
where it's going to send you to if
there's a login url and set the return
url and all this sort of stuff but this
authenticate async
has an http client injected into it
and it goes off and it passes over the
key thing with all of this
is we have to pass over the cookies
um and we pass over all the cookies
because session comes from a cookie
and i know what it's called but i worry
that you can change it and people might
have changed it
so i just send all the cookies for
authorization i send all cookies and
also the authorization header if it's
got one
and then i'm basically going to to the
back end application going hey run your
authentication
and then tell me what happens and then
if we get that back here
um we can say
uh deserialize that principle
into an actual claims principle and then
we can create an authentication ticket
and then that sets the user property on
the http context for the rest of this
request
to a claims principle that has all the
same claims roles
all that sort of stuff as it did on the
back end
now one thing this won't handle at the
moment is windows authentication
um it does not like serializing
windows identities because they're even
worse than just
normal claims identities and there are
two
aspects to this one is
this is all going to be on an open
source project and if somebody really
needs it
then they can submit it and go if it's a
windows
identity then then do it like this two
is stop using windows authentication
seriously just just
stop stop doing it it's it doesn't work
anymore
uh things windows authentication doesn't
work properly with
linux for a start mac that doesn't work
there
we've got kerberos um which is just
people trying to disguise the fact that
this is a proprietary authentication
protocol
by giving it an open name and blaming
mit
but more important than that windows
authentication doesn't work with http 2.
it just doesn't there's something about
http 2 that's
you they cannot make windows
authentication work over http 2
and you want to be moving everything to
http 2. actually you want to be moving
everything to http
3 sometime this year because that's
already supported in some browsers and
cloudflare and other places
so yes if you're using windows
authentication
stand up an active directory federation
server and start using it to get tokens
and then use those tokens to
authenticate your web services or grpc
services
and everything else that is the way to
go so yes
anyway so i've i've authenticated
people in my uh front-end application
as well as in my back-end application so
if i go here and i log in
i'm going to log it no go away
admin and p a dollar dollar word
don't blame me that's the password it
came with out of the git repository
and we log in here and you can see that
over here we've got hello admin and
logout
and we've switched to a different cart
now because i'm logged in i've got three
items in my cart from the last time i
logged in
so look there we go shopping cart's not
found though so
not everything is working beautifully i
need to fix that
but if i get that tilde out of there
then that works um and if i go to admin
i can get to the admin page because i am
logged in and this is
under wingtip toys too if i go to admin
uh
let me log in here and do admin
and p word
i can have both of these at the same
time because
the cookies some of the cookies are
being set for two four oh one nine and
the cookies that are set for five zero
zero one
are completely separate cookies so if i
go into admin here
you can see this was the product admin
page in this web forms application and
it's just
it's really really web forms you can
tell that it's where you can tell that
this was made by somebody who thought
they were writing a windows forms
application and so to
illustrate why sort of doing these
things is a good idea
i've made a lovely shiny bootstrappy um
admin page so this overrides this page
here
and adds all sorts of goodness into it
and does that do it yes this sentence
does do something
and so i can i can add pages there and i
need a cancel button
and all this sort of stuff so yeah but
that admin page
um in my
proxy application let me just go to here
and go to controllers and go to my admin
controller
and you can see i do actually have the
authorize attribute on there
so this is being authorized using
the authentication that was done by the
back end
using whatever the back end is and so
now
we have authentication being handled
as well now i may have forgotten
something but i think that's
pretty much it um
and i can't think of anything else if
anyone can think of anything else
just shout me in the chat or hit me up
on twitter or what about data protection
well theoretically data protection
um because you're relying on the web
forms application
and saying um you stole this
you just all you put this in session you
do all that side of things
um it should just be transparent
so because this is so let's say
we the back end servers using sql server
for session storage um and so it
encrypts things that are going into sql
server using its own data protection key
and so if i just went write another
session provider for asp.net core
that talks to that same sql server thing
i would have to find some way to share
keys
between the front-end application and
the back-end application
but most of the stuff that's in
because we're just going to the back and
going give me this value out of
selection
um we i don't think we have to worry
about it i think it's probably okay
um talk to me offline and and explain
why i'm wrong um you know you want to
we'll have beers
um
but yes so i think this this covers most
of it
um and the only
other issue that i did run into
was when uh
the back end did a redirect so if you
try to access
a controlled page and it did a redirect
to the login page um
for some reason it used the fully
qualified so used an absolute url
and so you may find yourself browsing
http localhost 2401
and i could not figure out how to get
the back end to stop
doing that because it's buried somewhere
in the depths
of its login system and so
what i ended up having to do was
write a custom wrapper around
microsoft's reverse proxy
it's not particularly custom
but this is and the code to do this is
on the
microsoft reverse proxy github repo so
they know that you want to do it
but this
does exactly the same stuff as map
reverse proxy does
except it adds in a transformer
and a transformer is just something
where
uh when the proxy gets the response
before it sends it further sends it back
out to the
client it goes here's the response we
got
do things with it and then we can carry
on
and so i just put this transformer in
there to say does the
response have a location if the location
is an absolute uri
and it starts with our destination
prefix
which we've got from our proxy then just
turn it into a relative uri
instead and so that stopped that from
happening
now all of this niceness
all of this
hacking around and mapping things to
bites and sharing things between the
new app and the old app once i got it
working and
and i figured out that it was actually
viable and i thought it would be
something that people could actually use
um i wrapped it up into a new get
a couple of new get packages
and i actually asked people to help me
name it on twitter
because i'm terrible at naming things if
i named
it it would be called randomizer and
that wouldn't work and someone suggested
strangler i was like
no people don't want to use things that
are called strangler
i don't know martin talk to me
afterwards
um but i thought cocoon
cocoon is a nice thing that wraps itself
around something that's
usually quite fugly actually um the
things that go into cocoons
tend not to be very pretty i'm just
saying nothing against
caterpillars but yeah and then the
things that come out of cocoons
six months later or however long that
takes beautiful
flappy things that flit around the place
and do lovely things and also moths
which are just stupid
and just fly at what did moths fly at
before light bulbs were invented
inquiring minds need to know so anyway
this is now what i'm doing on my twitch
stream is i'm i'm kind of writing cocoon
and
and building it and stuff and
i'm doing it it's sort of related to
what i've been doing with things like uh
gr converting wcf to grpc
uh with the commercial product that i
work on which is visual recode
um but visual recode is
uh it doesn't have any runtime stuff it
just changes your code
and so i didn't want to kind of mix the
two things up
um this is components this is stuff that
you're actually expecting to pick up and
put into your application and put into
your runtime
and so i wanted this to be open source
and so it is
and it's on github under the visual
recode organization at cocoon
it's apache 2.0 which
is i think the right license for it
if someone tells me i'm wrong and it
should be mit then
they can talk to me um but it is open
source it's on there
preview packages have started to go up
onto nougat
although honestly i i wouldn't start
trying to use it just yet
um i'm going to try and stand it up in
front of a couple of
gnarly web forms applications that i've
been working on and seeing if i can get
it to work there
and at that point i will sort of mark it
as beta and say if it works for this
it may very well work for whatever it is
you're doing
um so the other sort of question
that comes up about this is
you can we i have established that you
can replace
um web forms with mvc
views from an asp.net core mvc
application
i have checked um and it is also
possible to do it with razer pages
if you put razor pages into your
pipeline before the proxy it will find
those
as well um and i asked today on twitter
um whether you could mix blazer into
a normal asp.net application or
because i wasn't sure i thought maybe
blazer was purely a single page a spa
kind of thing and once you're in blazer
you stay in blazer
but it turns out that you can make
blazer components and then just host
them
in regular uh razer pages just using the
component tag helper
and so if you wanted to rewrite your web
forms application
into blazer then you could do that
as well and you can use blazer server
side or blazer web assembly
and so pretty much any pattern you could
want to use and obviously
you can also create uh mvc pages or
razor pages that use something like
spelt or view.js or react
and as long as it's not like a single
page a spa
you should be okay and once you've got
it all migrated across if you want to
turn it into a spa
then you can but the
docs for that
where are they let me just grab them for
you
because that's quite a long link
i'm going to put the link to the blazer
bit in the chat
there there you go
so yes um that is essentially all i had
to show you
and um i hope that
it looks like something that people
might go oh you know what
i i could potentially see us doing that
because the first step of just
creating the reverse proxy and spinning
it up and you can have your reverse
proxy running
on on a linux instance or you can just
run it in the same iis that the ht
the web forms application is running in
um
but yeah that first step is essentially
zero risk
um you're just kind of going i now have
a reverse proxy in front of my
application
and and everything should just continue
to work
um and then you can just go well maybe
i'll just read with the privacy page or
i'll just redo the amount we've got
we've got these static pages maybe i'll
just redo those
and just ease into it gradually and then
you know do do the admin pages for your
website
um because people are more forgiving
uh if something goes wrong in the admin
pages and it's not customer facing
and gradually build up to the point
where you're kind of going yes we can
now replace the home page
with our new asp.net core
mvc razer rendered view page
and do all that sort of thing i will
stick
that in the slack as well where is the
slack
i've lost the slack
i know it's over here somewhere hello
slack there we go
uh what track are we i don't know what
track i'm in
track four there we go
so yes there's the link in the slack as
well
and once i'm done i will also put all
the links
to all the things into the slack
for people to pick up from there so in
summary
the idea is to use microsoft reverse
proxy stick it in front of a web forms
application
and intercept some of the page requests
uh to do this
you have to deal with session and
authentication
and a couple of other sort of issues
that are specific
to doing this oh track five
let's put it in track five then there we
go yeah that looks more like it
with your cookie monster gif well done
um
track four is proxy of track five now
nice um
so yeah to do this i am creating cocoon
to handle things like session and
authentication and all this sort of
stuff
also you can follow me on twitter uh
twitter.com
and you can come and watch me work on
cocoon
and talk nonsense pretty much like i
have for the last hour
but live and improvised and
um and generally even more tired uh on
my twitch stream at
twitch.tv.markfrindle
um i will be around in the
i'll stay in the track room for 10
minutes
to answer questions if anybody has them
or you can ping me at twitter and ask me
on there as well
uh thank you so much for coming to this
talk
i really hope it was very helpful and i
really really really hope i will see you
in person
at some time soon maybe next year
um uh or maybe before that
take care of yourselves and i will
hopefully see you with the quiz tonight
as well
me and dylan doing a quiz eight o'clock
be there or don't
cheers bye